what people want is action not words and
what we suggested is that there's a
requirement on lenders to take these
measures because they're going to be
many many mortgage holders many many
families across the country who are now
even more worried about paying their
mortgage that's on top of all the other
bills and they know that the
government's failed now for 13 years
they know the government crashed the
economy last year what they want I think
is a much stronger sense the government
is gripping this action not word and
that's why we the labor party said look
let's require lenders to do this so that
it's not left the individual to come
forward many people will be reluctant to
do that because they'd be worried that
or reflect on their credit rating so
let's sort this out with a requirement
on the lenders to do this